is getting ready to host its first
professional franchise
when the silver knights skate into the
new hockey barn costing 84 million
dollars
we showed you the new renderings of the
facility last night today we get
reaction
john treach is live where the new
facility will be built
right there standing at the henderson
pavilion site hey john
hey there chris it is a pioneering
project for henderson imagine
a professional sports arena that can
draw thousands here in henderson
for a crowd that may not even be die
hard hockey fans indeed
a bold and ambitious task for both the
golden knights and the builders because
for the sake of the town
and the team they need to get it right
on day one
this is their first professional sports
team to put you know to put their name
on it and
uh we want to we want to do it right we
want to be great partners
and we want them to be proud um as much
as the neighborhood and the entire city
there's that element and then on top of
it we want our players
to know that that that commitment both
at the nhl and the american hockey
league level
is to provide them the best facilities
where they can be the best
that they can be and so what we're doing
with lifeguard arena which is on water
street
that'll be the finest american hockey
league facility in the country
and then to give them their own home in
the city of henderson
it just makes it that much more better
and again it's just it's one more piece
of the puzzle
as we try to build um you know the best
nhl
organization we can be
yeah and president kerry buboltz also
admitted to me that
he loves what las vegas did with las
vegas ballpark in summerlin and how
that's an attraction for
families and non-baseball fans for that
area and for all of sports fans
really in the valley in nevada and he
imagines that being the case here
in henderson reporting live john treach
eight sports now thank you very much